esta es la portada al mar unas
principales vías de cali que conecta la
ciudad con el océano pacifico y que
también desde el 28 de abril cuando
empezó el paro nacional de colombia
contra la reforma tributaria del
gobierno iván duque ha sido uno de los
puntos estratégicos de las protestas y
donde se han registrado enfrentamientos
entre policía y manifestantes como se
puede ver detrás de mí hay escombros que
son restos de esos enfrentamientos pero
también ahora mismo se pueden ver a los
militares que ayer en la noche del
sábado 1 de mayo día del trabajador el
presidente iván duque anunció que iba a
desplegar por las ciudades que lo
necesitasen también en este punto en la
portada del mar nos ha llamado la
atención la situación y es que como
pueden ver detrás de mí en la bomba en
la estación de gasolina se puede ver una
larga fila de coches para repostar unas
filas que se repiten también en bancos y
se repiten en supermercados por miedo al
de base este cimiento y es que mañana
también está previsto para el lunes un
paro nacional de camioneros y de
taxistas sin embargo es de
responsabilidad destacar que la mayoría
de protestas desde el 28 de abril en
colombia han sido pacíficas y lo que se
ha estado denunciando por parte de
organizaciones humanitarias y de
organizaciones sociales es abusos
policiales que podrían haber causa
la muerte de decenas de personas también
en la jornada de ayer sábado 1 de mayo
día del trabajador